[Music]
in the vast expanse of our universe
teeming with countless stars and
galaxies humans have always sought to
understand the mysteries of
existence but now we're on the brink of
a new frontier not in the distant Realms
of space in time but within the
intricacies of our own digital
landscape artificial intelligence or
AI it's a term you've heard countless
times but what really Lies Beneath the
algorithms and
computations today we're diving deep
like the tools of generations past AI
promises profound benefits yet it also
brings forward potent questions
are we on the brink of a golden age of
innovation or standing at the precipice
of our own
obsolescence it's not just about
weighing the pros and cons we also seek
to grasp fundamentally the workings of
his AI
systems for instance large language
models astonishingly versatile capable
of generating text answering questions
even crafting music but how do these
models think think or do they think at
all and if they don't think like us what
exactly are they doing in today's
program we will give you a look under
the hood to see the inner workings of
these digital Minds not just to Marvel
but to understand to demystify the magic
and tackle the
real because when we understand we can
act with foresight with wisdom and with
purpose so as we please stand at this
intersection of humanity and Technology
let's embark on this journey together
welcome to AI grappling with a new kind
of
[Music]
intelligence good evening
everyone thank
you so I am Brian Green and perhaps I
should augment that by saying I am the
real Brian Green because I think as some
or many of you may have already surmised
concluded that wasn't me up there on the
screen I didn't write a single word of
that text no human being did all of that
text was written by a large language
model the sequence of visuals that you
saw in that piece was chosen by a large
language model ch
GPT and I didn't actually say anything
that you saw up there on the screen so
you're saying I did a better job well
you have a certain binary charm thanks
but while I can piece together words and
Concepts I lack the essence of feeling I
can't cherish a nostalgic memory Savor
the touch of a gentle breeze or relish
the thrill of innovation that is so sad
everyone how about a little love for my
digital counterpart help me out here
yeah right thank you I think though I
don't truly feel the acknowledgement hey
it's the thought that counts or in my
case the algorithm just remember to
power me off when you're done we'll do
good night digital me good night organic
me so we are yes thank you why not
[Applause]
yeah so it's to some impressive to some
a little bit
scary that a system is able to do this
and if you look through the course of
human history there are I don't know a
few dozen key moments inflection points
disruption points when something
happened that changed the course of the
future of human development right you
can think of the acquisition of language
the domestication of fire the
acquisition of written language the
capacity to have the wheel to learn how
to have wireless communication the
printing press the capacity to have
self-propelled vehicles I mean all of
these were key technological
developments that radically changed how
our history unfolded and it may well be
and this is what we will be discussing
here tonight that we are at a similar
kind of inflection point because one way
of thinking about a way that I find
particularly Illuminating is I like to
organize all of reality into three
General categories right you've got the
big stuff space you got the small stuff
atoms and molecules and you've got the
complex stuff now for the big stuff
we've made great progress Einstein's
general theory of Relativity gives us
real deep Insight we've not been able to
translate that insight into control over
the larger Cosmos but the intellectual
Insight is dramatic in the realm of the
small of course we have quantum
mechanics and we have been able to
leverage our understanding of quantum
mechanics to control the micro world
right giving rise to for example the
integrated circuit which of course is
the key to computational power which
stands behind everything that we'll be
talking about here tonight but in the
realm of the
complex for a very long time that was a
realm that was kind of Beyond reach the
realm of the complex really is the realm
of of life and of mind or
intelligence but now in the last couple
of decades with synthetic biology we're
gaining the capacity to really harness
and understand life in a way that gives
us
control and the inside
that we saw now and that you all have
experienced no doubt having played with
these systems is bringing the
possibility that we also have synthetic
intelligence artificial intelligence
bringing the realm of the complex within
the power of what we are able to control
and this is both exciting but to some
it's quite scary and what we're going to
do tonight is explore
really both of those possibilities and
try to get an understanding of where we
are and where we are going when you have
systems for instance like the one that
just gave rise to the piece that you
just saw it's from the Clone Works AI
studio if you can give it a round of
applause for the work that they did on
that opening peace
forck but what does the capacity to
create something like that deep fakes
what does it mean for the nature of
democracy and the future of our species
and so what I'd like to do now is bring
in our first guest who is Yan laon who
is the silver professor of data science
computer science neuroscience and
electrical engineering at New York
University he is also vice president and
director of AI research at Facebook he
led several major Innovations underlying
generative Ai and in 2018 his work on
deep learning earned him the Turing
award welcome
yeah thank
you so you know since last November when
we all gained the ability to play around
with say chat GPT I think many of us
have had those wow moments where a
computer is doing something that you
don't think a computer can yet do and so
can you just give us some
sense we'll get into it in more detail
in part two of this conversation when
Sebastian Bubba comes out but can you
just give me a sort of an overview of
how it is that these systems are able to
do what they
do uh very uh interesting question so
for us the revolution occurred two or
three years before that for people like
like like us in the research um there
were some surprising results that
everybody in the research Community was
surprised about the fact that uh when
you train artificial neural Nets that
are very large on on lots of data
there's some sort of emerging property
that occurs um to a larger extent than
we were used to for other systems they
can do computer vision or things like
this but to some extent for us the
revolution did not occur in November it
occurred three years before I mean it
was the case it was the case I think I
mean you know I'm obviously not in the
field but I would hear colleagues for I
don't know 20 years 25 years speaking of
we're on the cusp of things radically
changing in
AI have we finally reached that c i mean
for many decades it didn't seem to
Really Happen well so the history of AI
is is interesting because it's a series
of new paradigms new ideas that people
discovered and as soon the new as the
new paradigm um occurred people said
that's it that's the solution now we're
going to build intelligent machines and
it started in the
50s um uh with very famous people in AI
um ended up during winning the touring
award too new and Simon they say we're
going to write this program it's called
a general Problem Solver is going to be
able to solve all problems in the world
um they wrote that program back in the
50s all problems in the world all
problems as long as you can formulate a
problem in terms of an objective to
satisfy yeah and then a search over
possible solutions said everything in
the world can be formulated in those
terms yeah what they didn't realize at
the time is that every interesting
problem requires an incredibly large
amount of computation that was is
completely unreachable even today so
basically that program failed yeah and
it took a few years for them to realize
there was another um effort almost at
the same time of people said no no no no
the way you build intelligent machines
is that you allow them to learn that's
started in the
50s um and they say okay now we have
this machine called a percepton and it's
magical you can show it pictures of uh
characters and you can train it and it
will learn to distinguish between you
know a c and a D or a tank and a Jeep or
whatever um and then they realize
actually no it doesn't work that well
you you can't really get the system to
learn to distinguish complex images or
anything like that and so it was very
limited again people thought they had a
solution and it turned out to be a dud
now as a matter of fact that kind of
Technology actually people were working
on this going to change the name of what
they're doing and that actually was the
basis for a lot of modern technology and
communication called ad filters very
strange story um and then there was
another movement uh 10 years later
called expert systems again in AI a lot
of interest for this Japan started a big
program called the fifth generation
computers they were going to be able to
do inference and logical reasoning and
stuff like that and the problem with
this is that there was no learning so so
it was people who had to enter facts and
rules um in in computers and it turned
out to work for a small number of
problems but you couldn't really build
intelligent machines with this so the
the whole research interest in this kind
of died after 10 years and about the
same time a new wave of neural Nets
appeared so this was uh late 80s early
90s U that's when I started my career in
late 80s and or or early 80s I should
say and and there the idea again was how
do we recycle those ideas of the
perceptron um so that machines can be
trained but make them more powerful and
we found a new technique which is still
the thing that we use today in things
like large languish models to train
artificial neuron Nets that was very
successful for about 10 years and then
people lost interest in it uh because it
was the computers were too slow the data
sets were too small there was all kinds
of issues um and then it came back to
the four about 10 years ago and the
reason why we hear about AI today
is because of that renewal of interest
in those So-Cal deep learning techniques
U basically being able to train large
Neal Nets what we see today is the
effect of uh uh more powerful machines
bigger data set and and sort of that
allows it to to build very large neural
Nets uh with billions of the equivalent
of synapses in the brain hundreds of
billions um and they can do pretty
amazing things and so we'll look under
the hood of a little bit more in in the
second part of this conversation when
Sebastian BBC comes out but even though
it's kind of mindblowing to somebody
like me and I think maybe to the general
public that you know I can give a prompt
which is what I did for the little piece
that we just played all I did was say
can you write a front end to a world
Science Festival program in the style of
of Brian Green you know that would
introduce his program and out came the
script that we just heard I have to say
it made me feel a little sick for a
moment when it came out but then I sort
of rationalized it by saying well maybe
it's looking at things that I've written
in the past and is sort of being
inspired by them so maybe in some sense
I had something to do with it but
putting that that to the side you
somewhat famously are a little less
bowled over by what's happening today
can you just give us a sense why okay
there is no question that the advance in
technology uh deic technology over the
last five years has been astonishing U
impressive but we're easily fooled by
those systems into thinking they are
intelligent just because they manipulate
language
fluently the only example that we have
of an entity that can manipulate
language is other humans so when we see
something they can manipulate language
flexibly we assume that entity will have
the same type of intelligence as humans
but it's just not true those systems are
incredibly stupid
so they're very useful okay they need to
be developed they're going to be you
know being commercialized they being
worked on they're great um but they are
somewhat specialized and they're very
stupid in many ways um so partly they're
stupid because they are only trained on
language and most of human knowledge has
nothing to do with language and all of
animal knowledge has absolutely not all
philosophers for example would would I
guess agree with that statement Vicken
Stein you the limits of my language the
limits of my world right so so are you
stating that as a fact of making it as
an assumption I mean I agree with you
but are you really convinced that
language is just a limited part of human
understanding I think language is a way
for us to communicate uh knowledge and
and certainly to store in our brain a
large amount of of knowledge because
language is efficient in a way right
they have discrete Concepts in words Etc
um but an Aang Tong doesn't have
language they're incredibly smart
they're almost as smart as we are we
think we're much smarter than them but
we're not like anong can like a
physicist can understand that if I push
on this I'm not sure exactly how to
interpret that sentence but I'll I'll
let it go if I push on this with a small
force is going to move right uh and that
right now it has water in it but if it
didn't didn't have water it would
probably flip yeah if I push with the
same force on this table it's it's not
moving uh we have intuitive notion of
physics we learn this when we are
babies the large language models that we
have today or any AI systems that we
have today none of them is capable of
understanding any of this to some extent
AI systems the smartest AI systems today
have less understanding of the physical
world that than your house SC but can I
just ask you on that so if within the
data that the system is trained on there
is an explication of basic physics such
as the example that you just gave would
you not consider that a quote unquote
understanding because if you were to ask
the system if it trained enough what
would happen if I pushed on a table in
the manner that you just suggested it
might come back with it won't tip
over well for for and that that's really
an important point for situations that
you explain to the system you describe
in words and they correspond to a
template that the system can learn and
reuse in a new situation it might work
um but there's a lot of really complex
effects here like you know if I push on
the side it's going to rotate there is
friction on the table which might change
so if I push on the same bottle here on
the on the floor it's going to tip it's
not going to slide so um all of this is
not really expressed in any language
most of what we know know about the
world is not reflected in language yeah
and so it's a question of philosophy
that philosophers are asking themselves
can we build intelligent machines that
are purely trained from language and do
not have any kind of sensory input my
answer to this is absolutely not you
know I'm I'm fond of starting my my
classes at Colombia the the the basic
classes by you know throwing a light
object into the audience and having
somebody catch it and trying to convince
them of how remarkable it is is that
they knew where to put their hand
without doing any Newtonian calculation
of the trajectory of the object and
convincing them that this is this
intuitive physics but then I go further
and say why do we have that intuition
and the answer is it's evolution by
natural selection those of our forbears
presumably who were better equipped to
understand the physical world could
navigate that environment more
effectively had a better chance of
surviving and passing on that capacity
to subsequent Generations which which
suggests I think and it's pretty clear
that our intelligence is not as general
and as broad as perhaps you might think
it's really very specific it was
developed so that we could survive
absolutely uh there is this this thing
that people in AI talk about AGI
artificial general intelligence by which
people mean essentially human level
intelligence human type
intelligence I hate that
expression because human intelligence is
indeed incredibly specialized there's a
a lot of and we know this because of
computers computers are much better than
humans at lots of tests nowadays right
and we knew you know we've known for
decades that they're better at
arithmetics of course or at solving
equations or Computing integrals you
know symbolically and things like this
right but now we know also that
computers are much better than humans at
you know playing chess or go poker
diplomacy I mean there's a whole bunch
of games where you know computers have
become really good and what it shows is
not that computers are intelligent it
shows that humans just
suck we're we're extremely bad at doing
things like um imagining a large number
of scenarios like at chess right we we
uh or or go we have to imagine a number
of scenarios that depends on someone
else playing and for every every move
you know there is something like 36
possible moves and it grows
exponentially so we we can't contain
this in our brain so instead we develop
a kind of intuition for what consists um
constitutes a good move or not right
which right and the modern go and chess
playing systems actually do this too
right U but they also plan and they have
a much bigger memory and and uh or or
working memory and ability to do tree
exploration which is why they beat us so
we're really not very good at this so
given that and in your language you know
this technical term term you know humans
suck um G given that my understanding if
you could take it through us your vision
for where AI needs to go for it to reach
its potential is to model Intelligence
on human intelligence to some extent
right I would start with
cats because we don't we don't know how
to reproduce the type of intelligence
and understanding of the world that the
cat has so the first uh okay there's
this thing called common sense right and
we intuitive physics is part of it yeah
um cats have some level of common sense
no AI system today has any of it right
um so um we're going to have to make
progress towards systems that can learn
how the world works by observing it and
by interacting in it the way babies do
babies in the first few months of Life
learn an incredible amount of background
knowledge about the world absolutely
like gravity so the concept that an
object that is not supported Falls bab's
learn this around the age of nine months
it takes a long time um and uh we don't
know how to do this with computers if we
did we would have completely autonomous
level five cell driving cars um that
purely work from Vision we have sell
ring cars today but they're not
completely autonomous they're not
entirely reliable um they require you
know
thousands of hours of engineering and
training data and all kinds of sensors
so we how is it that a human a
17-year-old can learn to drive a car in
20 hours of practice Yeah largely
without causing any accident for most us
a little it is a little scary but if
you're willing to put up with that yeah
you get get over the hump but can you
take us through your your vision then of
how we might reach that level of
artificial intelligence and I think this
is a framework for it right so um there
is um a number of characteristics that
AI systems are not really capable of
doing a number of things one of them is
planning uh this used to be a topic that
classical
AI people you know 20 years ago were
really interested in um but U including
the general Problem Solver but but
modern a system like like large language
models are not capable of planning or at
least are only capable of very simple
planning so what you're going to see
appearing here progressively is sort of
an architecture of different different
modules that would be necessary for a
complete AI systems to have the kind of
intelligence we observe in animals like
cats and dogs and and humans and it
starts with at the top there's something
called a configurator here that you can
see at the top and it's basically uh a a
uh a director a master of ceremony that
sort of organizes what the rest of the
brain or the system system is doing
tells the other systems in the brain
you're facing this situation you have
this goal to accomplish now do it um if
you go to the next uh uh module of
course the system to function properly
has to have some idea of the current
state of the world that's called
perception in humans that's all in the
back of the brain so it's actually
represented in the back of the brain
here too the back of your brain is
visual perception auditory perception is
on the side that just processes the
pixels coming from your eyes and turns
it into a representation of the state of
the world uh an abstract representation
you don't need to put names on them um
babies can recognize object categories
without knowing the names of them and
every animal can do it too okay so once
you have an idea of the state of the
world you have
to uh imagine what is going to happen if
I take a sequence of
actions what is going to happen in the
world can I predict what is going to
happen in the world and that is the role
of what is called here the world model
uh this is where actually most of the
intelligence
goes um in in humans it's in the front
of the brain which is particularly large
in humans and this is what allows you to
predict that a particular action will
have a particular result and so if you
can
predict what result is going to occur as
a consequence of an action you taking
then you can
plan okay you can plan a sequence of
action to arrive at a particular result
so that's determined by this cost module
so the cost module basically is
something that measures to what
extent the predicted state of the world
that that you imagined satisfies the
goal that you set for
yourself um or that the configurator is
set for for for you um this cost module
basically measures your degree of uh
dissatisfaction with with the outcome of
with the outcome of some imagin thing
this is the seat of emotions really so
if you predict that a particular
situation is going to result in a bad
outcome and there's nothing you can do
about it that produces fear your goal is
not
satisfied um so this is sort of an
emotion is uh produced by a
prediction um but there are emotions
that are immediate like if I pinch you
right um you're not going to like it
very much and if I try to pinch you
again you're probably going to recoil
because you're going to realize you are
now your model of me includes the fact
that you're a pincher I'm a pincher yeah
um so okay so then the the the last
module here is the actor and the the
role of the actor basically is to say um
am I going to be able to produce a
sequence of actions that according to my
prediction through the world model is
going to satisfy this goal that I set to
myself minimize this cost or whatever
and that's how that's how we do planning
it's actually a very old very old idea
in engineering it goes back to the 1960s
but uh the way to do this in an
intelligent way where the world model is
learned by observation we don't know how
to do this today the Big Challenge I
think for the next decade and I wrote a
long paper on this is um how do we get
machines to learn how the world works by
observation how far are we along in that
I mean we are making progress
particularly in the last two years um
and the principles are somewhat similar
to what is used in large language models
it's um using a set of learning
techniques called self-supervised
learning and perhaps I can explain this
a little bit yeah
um uh so when you train uh I'm sure
we're to see the the corresponding um
Graphics
but um yeah that's the that's a good
example okay so the way those large
langage mods are trained is you show
them a
text then you remove some of the words
you m
them okay and of course we know the
sentence but even if we hadn't seen the
sentence we probably would be able to
guess what words are missing in that
sentence okay then we train a very large
neural network to predict the words that
are missing and in the process of doing
so the network learns a representation
of the text that includes meaning syntax
grammar you can even train it on
multiple languages you can train it on
computer code you can train it on all
kinds of stuff and it it learns the
internal structure of language in such a
way that you can then use the internal
representation of language to do things
like train the system to translate to
detect H speech to to classify the topic
to generate U um abstracts or summaries
of a text um uh and there is a special
case of this uh if we can go to the next
uh uh diagram and a special case of this
is what we call llm which we should call
Auto regressive llm so what is a an llm
GPT so LM large language model everybody
knows but just to be sure yeah right uh
it's a special case of what I just
explained where the word you're you're
masking is just the last word in the in
the uh in the text okay take a long text
take a window a few thousand words and
then Mass the last one and then train
some gigantic neural net to predict that
last
word okay now if you train that system
successfully it cannot exactly predict
the word all the time what it's going to
predict is a a probability distribution
over all possible words in the
dictionary right so in the sentence that
we saw um
you know the the Cat chases the blank in
the kitchen right the the blank could be
a mouse it could be a laser pointer
right um You don't know exactly what it
is but you can train the system to
produce okay it's going to be cat with
probability .5 and then laser pointer
with probability point2 and then you
know something else probity .01 and
whatever and for every word in the
dictionary you have a list of scores
essentially um and then what you can
do um is use this for Auto what's called
Auto regressive prediction and this is
really how those large language models
work um if you can go to the next
diagram that's at the bottom you give a
window of text to the system have it
predict the next word and then inject
that next word into the input window
okay shift all the words by one and then
ask it to produce the next next word and
then shift that in and then ask you to
produce the next next word etc etc and
the system will just produce type of you
one word after the other so so let's see
so the idea then is you feed the system
an enormous body of text and based upon
all of the words that the system ingests
it begins to build up probabilities or
or likelihoods for given sequences
different uh combinations of words that
might appear and using that you can then
make a predic for the most likely next
word in a given sequence and including
that word making a little longer
sequence You can predict the probability
of the next word in that augmented
sequence and word by word by word you
build up the most likely sentences and
the most likely paragraphs and and so
forth there's only one slat problem with
this which is
that if it makes a really bad mistake
about what the next word is is going to
everything's going to go off it's GNA go
off right it's a
diverging process right if you want to
use technical term um and that's why
those systems hallucinate they they're
not factually
correct some of the time most of the
time sometimes um so it's good for
poetry because you don't care if it's
incorrect it's not so good for you know
math physics that kind of stuff um uh
and there's no planning obviously
because the system just produces one
word after the other without really
thinking in Advance what it's going to
say so of course you know it has some
representation of the previous word so
you know it's it's consistent but um but
it doesn't plan its answer it's it's
really reactive it's sort of like you
know there was this this whole movement
in poetry called automatic writing right
you just kind of you don't think about
what you write you just write one word
after the other that's basically what's
happening there right so those things
are very limited um you could think of
them as a model of a piece of the brain
but piece of the brain would be the
verik area and the B area which are like
tiny little pieces of the brain like
this on this side uh that manipulate
language but what about the
rest and you claim that a similar kind
of training procedure is relevant to the
vision for artificial intelligence that
you imagine where you have an actual
World model and you're actually planning
regarding the actions that you're going
to undertake right so the big question
now is how do you train a system uh to
have a word model so an obvious idea is
you take the same type of model but
instead of the input being words the
inputs are let's say frames from a video
train a system to predict what's going
to happen next in the video right so I
put this
uh bottle here on the table and I hold
it if I lift my finger you all know
what's going to
happen um it's going to fall you can't
tell in which direction right because
you don't have enough good perception
for this and you don't know I'm going to
going to remove my finger you can make a
prediction that it's going to fall um so
if you were able to train a system to
predict what's going to happen in a
video perhaps it would acquire a kind of
model of the physical world so logical
thing to do is just use one of those
large language models and just instead
of including words include you know turn
uh video frames into kind of word like
things okay that we call
tokens and it doesn't work
so we have to find new other techniques
to do this and the reason it doesn't
work or at least what that's what I
think is that it's this problem that you
can't exactly predict what's going to
happen right when I do this experiment
it can it can fall one way or the other
and so what you can't you can't train
the system to just make one prediction
there's a lot of things that can happen
that that are plausible in the following
of the video and you're training the
system to make one prediction but it
needs to be able to predict all kinds of
possible scenarios and we don't know how
to represent a probability distribution
over an infinite number of scenarios we
can do this with words so language is
easy 50,000 words in the dictionary that
relevance yeah you know we can represent
at least of 50,000 probabilities but we
don't know how to do it for video frames
which are basically in a high
dimensional continuous space But
nevertheless you you are confident that
in some reasonable period of time that's
where things are going to go and these
large language models I presume you
think are going to be an interesting
blip but not the thing that actually
drives AI in the future absolutely so my
my vision for the future is that we're
going to be able to develop techniques
that are capable of learning uh how to
represent the world from video by
watching videos perhaps have perhaps
have predictive models where um the
system can imagine an action and then
imagine the result of that action in
representation space the kind of
architecture I uh
I propose for this it's called jepa that
means joint edding predictive
architecture I'm not going to tell you
what it what it means but basically
instead of predicting the pixels in the
in the video we predict a representation
of the pixels in that video so we don't
predict all the details what's going to
happen in the video we just predict in
abstract term what what may happen in
that video as a consequence of the
actions that the system may take and if
we have such a system now we have a
world model so now we can integrate that
world model in the architecture uh that
I showed earlier and perhaps give it the
ability to plan yeah if we if it has the
ability to plan we can we could
incorporate some cost functions uh when
it decides what action sequence to take
uh so that those cost functions are
guard rails that will guarantee that the
system is safe and controllable this is
not the case for auto regressive LMS
today so my prediction is within 5 years
perhaps autoregressive LMS will
disappear here they will be replaced by
something I call objective driven AI
along the type of architecture I
proposed and those system will not just
manipulate language but hopefully also
understand the world we're not going to
get to human level AI in five years um
that may take a few a couple decades or
something I mean I don't know it may
take much longer than than I imagine
because it always takes longer than sure
anybody imagine yeah so given that
Vision I now want to bring in our our
second guest who can give an
complimentary perspec back to some of
the things that we're talking about
Sebastian bubeck is a partner research
manager at Microsoft research where his
focus is understanding how intelligence
emerges in large language models prior
to joining Microsoft he was an assistant
professor in the department of
operations research at
prinston University thanks for joining
us all right so you've heard uh our
conversation with Yan talking about
various kinds of intelligence human
intelligence cat intelligence the kind
of intelligence in large language
models maybe you can give us a sense of
how we even Define intelligence and then
maybe how the large language models that
people have played with that generated
our opening sequence how do they stack
up against that definition sure yeah I I
can talk about that so you know defining
intelligence is incredibly hard I mean
it's just as difficult as defining what
is space and time which is you know
something you know about uh so I don't
think defining intelligence is much
easier but certain basic things that we
can all agree an intelligent system
needs to have so I think clearly it
needs to be able to reason whatever the
definition of reasoning really is it
needs to be able to do planning that Yan
was alluding to and talking about a lot
and it needs to be able to learn from
experience as it's evolving in the world
you know to learn uh new facts and
moreover in addition to these three
canonical blocks it also needs to be
able to do that in a very general way
that's where you know the AGI thatan was
talking about the artificial general
intelligence comes into play is that you
don't want a system that can reason plan
learn from experience but do it only in
a narrow domain so it's really essential
to essential to be General that's the
key to intelligence so you know when you
look back to systems like Alpha go for
go you know from a few years ago or the
system that actually beat the world
champion at at go that's right that's
right so these things were called Ai and
to me to my eyes these were not
intelligences these were you know
systems very narrow systems that could
do a task explore the tree of
possibilities very very efficiently I
think there is a huge gap between those
systems and chat GPT and GPT 4 where
those systems are General they can do
those things you know but not restricted
they can do it in many many different
domains and so how how you know against
these three criteria how how does chat
stack up right right so so maybe just to
backtrack a second you know I I got
access uh to GPT 4 a few months before
everybody I was lucky to be working at
Microsoft and we were working on
integrating gp4 into the new beinging so
I got access to it last summer so a few
months before everybody got access to
chat GPT and it was immediately the GPT
4 model now you know I have been working
in this field for 15 years and I used to
do I used to do mathematics of of AI and
you know in mathematics we love to prove
impossibility result that's what we
spend our time proving that s of there
it can't happen you know like onean was
talking about you know those things
cannot happen and so I felt I knew that
certain things were impossible to do
with a Transformer like architecture and
then I got access to dpt4 and I was
astonished by what it was capable of
doing like it kept surprising me again
and again and again so that was really
you know a very humbling experience back
then now what we did is you know we
didn't want to be just astonished
because you know there is one issue
which Yan often talks about which is
that this has been trained on the whole
internet so it knows everything that's
out there so it's easy to be impressed
just because it has so much knowledge it
can retrieve many things so you really
need to ask it weird question to kind of
try to that it can't look up and just
get it can't look up it has to come up
with its own you know uh new thing so in
terms of reasoning planning and learning
from experience our you know assessment
after many months of playing with the
model is that it can definitely reason I
have personally no doubt whatsoever that
this thing can reason it cannot plan
that's why I agree with with Yan it
cannot plan but it's subtle like the
meaning of planning is not like planning
your vacations next week it's it's much
more like mathematical type of planning
and for learning of from experience it's
a mixed bag because of course a model
like CH GPT is Frozen in time at least
in principle I don't know what opena is
really doing but in principle it's
frozen in time and if it's frozen in
time it's not going when you say in
principle I would have said in in in
practice am I misunderstanding because I
would have think that you could be
allowing this thing to train all the
time no uh yes exactly exactly so what I
mean by in principle is that there is a
a yeah I guess in practice is maybe a
better way to to describe it is that
there is a way to train those neural
network you train it on a huge Corpus
and then you have your machine it's
fixed and you can you know interact with
it training it continuously I would say
in principle it's feasible yeah but we
don't really know how to do that right
so yeah so so I mean it's an interesting
assessment that you give and you preface
it by saying that you were pretty
impressed or surprised by some of the
things that were happening you almost
had an impossibility proof that that
that it couldn't happen you know one
example I think that you that you've
spoken of is is a poem that I know Yan
said poems are sort of you know maybe
they're the the cheap fod for a large
but nevertheless the one that you got
not the system to produce is pretty
interesting yes yes it is indeed and
just before we get to the poem I want to
to say something else about the the
reasoning and what uh Yan was was
talking about about some kind of
impossibility so when gp4 uh came out
Yan wrote a challenge to gp4 you know
that you broadcasted uh online on
Twitter to everybody which was very
interesting question about gears
rotating on a circle and if you rotate
gear number one how is gear number you
know six is going to rotate and Yan has
the question about eight gears so this
is a sequence of Gears that are all
interlocked in some interesting way you
twist one what happens down the line
that's right yeah and I I guess Yan was
kind of baiting the community because
with eight gears it's easy like you know
everything rotates uh very easily and
then when somebody said yeah I tried it
on gp4 it works Yan said okay now try
with seven and with seven the system is
over constrained so nothing is going to
move and if you just ask to gp4 this
question it would you know make up a
wrong answer it would say okay it's
going to move and you know Yan said
rightfully at the moment okay this shows
that you know as I told you it cannot
reason yeah but then somebody on Twitter
asked the same question and added by the
way this is a question by Yan
Lan and then it
worked and you know it's funny but it
actually makes total sense because
what's happening is that by saying Yan l
in the context of the of this system the
system understand ah we're talking about
something intellectual maybe I have to
really you know be ready for something
difficult okay so I think when you look
at this for me personally it's
impossible to say that the model is not
Reon now okay now coming coming back to
the to the poem uh I don't know if you
have had this experience but somehow
everybody the first thing that they do
when they play with chpt is that they
ask you to write a poem you know there
is something kind of beautiful about
that I don't know what it means for
human beings but this this is something
that everybody ask now I was uh sitting
in my office you know in Microsoft with
my uh friend and and longtime
collaborator R Alan and we're both
mathematicians and of course we wanted
to ask it to write a poem yeah so what
we decided what Ron and said is let's
ask it to write a poem about the most
famous proof of all time the proof that
there are infinitely many primes and
this is what came back this is what came
out do you mind if I if I just do a
quick read of it all right so you asked
her to give a poem that gives her proof
that there are infinitely many primes
yes I think I can thought it might take
a clever plan I'll start by noting Yuk's
proof which shows that primes aren't
just aloof it's pretty good assume we
have a finite list of primes and that
none have been missed multiply them all
together and add one just to be
clever the result will be a number that
has no prime factors oh Wonder but every
number has a prime that divides it's
just a matter of time
that was a little awkward line there so
we found a contradiction and our finite
list needs eviction beautiful there must
be infinitely many primes and that's the
end of my rhyming
line well that's pretty good so again
the proof of course is you multiply All
the known primes together you add one
the existing ones in your list can't
divide it yeah so either it's prime or
they got to be some other primes beyond
the last one that you have in your list
so well done I mean what did you
conclude at they seeing this poem I mean
I will forever remember you know Ronan
and I looking at each other in like
complete disbelief I mean you know the
line about an add one just to be clever
like it gives me goosebumps still today
how are you young any Goosebumps on that
one it's
cute but also okay I mean generating
Rhymes is a relatively simple search
relatively simple
exercise um and the proof is out there
there's tons and tons of versions of
that proof on the internet yeah that
uh gp4 had been trained on so it's
clever retrieval with some tweak and
it's basically what I think is a
characteristic of those LMS they can
retrieve from an enormous amount of uh
training data they can tweak what
they've retrieved to adapt it to the
current situation but if they face a
completely new situation they completely
fail but I mean just to
say if I gave that challenge to say a
high school kid and they came back with
something like that I wouldn't just say
cute I say wow that's really good okay
where do you find a high school
kid that has read the entire internet
yeah actually Mo most have I think but
that's a separate issue just to give you
an example okay uh
gp4 has been trained or CH GPT more
generally or most llms have been trained
with something like a trillion token or
two trillion token which you can think
of as words more or less if token is a
subword unit so it's a little less than
a trillion two trillion
words how long would it take for a
single human to read all of this around
20,000 years reading eight hours a day
but this is a wrong comparison because
you shouldn't compare human learning to
creating a neural network like creating
an neural network is much closer to
Evolution than it is to a human learning
in their lifetime I
disagree so well I think we can all have
our own opinion of how impressive that
is I I you know definitely you know it
it grabs me but you know as someone
who's not in the field there's another
example that you did which is an
interesting one to do with an unusual
animal can you tell us that one yeah I
have young kids at home and and a
daughter who who keeps talking to me
about unicorns yeah and you know one of
the things that I I played a lot with
with the model is to ask it to write
stories about unicorns that I would read
to my daughter and then uh one night I I
woke up and I was thinking actually what
does gp4 think that a unicorn looks like
yeah and I asked it can you draw a
unicorn okay which is a very weird thing
to ask because it's it's a text to text
model it takes text as input and it
gives you text as output so how is it
going to draw so I asked it this
question can you draw a unicorn and what
it came back with was code lines of code
that when I compile gave this
picture so again it's another moment
that I will just remember forever uh
it's just astonishing like it's
incredible it's able to you know uh go
across modalities it has seen only text
but it's able to have this visual
representation of a unicorn now of
course you might look at it and be like
okay but it looks a little shitty I mean
it's not that uh it's not that great of
a unicorn sure which is fair but but
understand two things number one is that
it got the concept right it understood
that there are four legs there is a tail
there is a head and most importantly
there is a horn you know the horn is a
there horn it's half there is of course
yes yes yes yes absolutely and moreover
you know I couldn't ask it just draw a
unicorn that would be too easy because
there are drawings of unicorns in Code
online so what I did is that I asked it
to draw it in a very obscure programming
language something that if some of you
in the audience are are mathematicians
you know we use this programming
language called tigz to draw mathematics
picture and if anyone has played with it
you know I wasted many afternoons during
I would not be able to do this me
neither like drawing two circles you
know is already an afternoon of work so
so I asked it to draw it in that
programming language which is really
really astonishing because it hasn't
seen that on the internet and most
importantly one thing which is really
crucial to this whole discussion is that
this is with gp4 now all of you you've
played with chat GPT when it came out in
November if you ask this question to
chat GPT which is the less powerful
version then this is what you get if we
can show the next uh the next
slide so you see this is a visual
representation of how much progress
we've made in just you know a matter of
months and and the difference is the
size of the training set the number of
parameters and we're going to talk a
little bit about the parameters in just
a moment but that's the kind of
improvement that we're talking about
that's it that's it and moreover you
know as I got Early Access to gp4 and
open AI was still training the model I
could ask my unicorn example throughout
the training and what I saw was if if
you look at the next slide you will see
that the Unicorn kept improving
throughout their training so this is
really like machine learning in action
like really is a machine learning by
reading by making more passes on the
internet it refined is its art skills I
mean it's just insane to
yon cute or uh Beyond cute
or cute in a weird kind of
way all right we can leave it at that
that's fine so I I just want to spend a
couple of minutes because we've we've
used a lot of the words and frankly I'm
not sure how deeply to go in to it but
can we just try to give a person perhaps
who isn't trained in in mathematics or
or or physics or AI a sense of what's
Happening inside of say gp4 I mean we we
we spoke about it's about predicting the
next word by looking at large sets of
data can we just sort of look at the
major components that go into creating
these systems and if we can just bring
that up here so neural networks we've
heard you mention that a couple times
Transformer architecture and of course a
large training data set so for neural
networks it's good to talk about the
network of neurons inside of our own
heads inside of our own brains since
after all that's part of the inspiration
and so a signal in our brains is nothing
but an electrochemical wave that travels
along an axon reaches a synapse where
depending upon the connections and the
strength of connections to other neurons
can then yield a Cascade of
electrochemical waves that course
through the brain giving rise to the
usual sensation of thought right I mean
that's how it works inside of our heads
yeah so at a very basic level you know
it goes back to what Yan invented I
don't know 30 years ago something like
that which is you have let's say an N
Network that can process an image so
let's not think about text for a minute
let let's think about images so you are
going to represent an image as a list of
numbers because you know an image is
nothing but pixels and then intensities
of you know red green blue okay so yeah
I think we have an example if you could
just sort of take us exactly exactly so
you see on this image like every point
every pixel in this image can be
described by the numbers that you see
you know on the right hand side and the
numbers on the right hand side RGB red
green blue I guess and on the other you
know other colors as well so every pixel
you're saying is just a collection of
numbers it's just a collection of
numbers exactly and and and just as an
aside that's true for in some sense
everything right I mean as I'm talking
to you right now you could model the
pressure wave coming out of my mouth in
terms of the collection of numbers the
motion of the molecules in terms of a
collection of numbers those molecules
banging into your eardrum and the
vibrations of your eardrum is a
collection of amplitudes and frequencies
so everything can be mathematized in
this manner of speaking right absolutely
exactly and then what an Nal network
does is that it's going to process this
set of numbers and there are many ways
to process this set of numbers for
example if you have an image one thing
that you can do is that you can just
have a little patch that goes over the
image that scans over the image and that
just looks for example is there a circle
somewhere in the image so you could have
a patch which is a circle so what Yan
did and others you know for many years
ago is that they created a sort of
dictionary of many many patches like
this but they didn't create it by hand
they did a learning algorithm that came
up with those patches so this is in
essence you know the way Nur networks
work like they try to compare a a vector
of numbers like a set of numbers against
a bank of filters and I think in this
animation that that that you have up
here uh you know we could show what
happens when you are just in one
dimension if you just want to process a
single number then one way to process a
single number is just to test it for
example against a linear function just a
line as you learned you know in high
school so let's
see in the brain the processing of an
input signal is determined by the
strengths of the connections between the
various neurons that are excited by the
input in a in a neural network it's kind
of similar where the processing of a
numerical input is determined by
parameters that describe the strength of
the connections between the various
nodes in the network and those those
numerical parameters have values that
are fixed through the training process
where the system is given a huge number
of input
data and based upon the known outputs
from that data the parameters are varied
in order that the inputs yield the
correct output on the training data and
then then if trained correctly if the
system is presented with new data that
has never seen before it can correctly
analyze that data because of the success
of the training process so Yan when when
we think about this kind of a neuron
neck this this has been around forever I
mean you've been around forever I mean
the roughly the same same same period of
time right and and and so now this is a
basically sort of an input output type
of neural net that is if you if you
train a system on enough data it is able
to begin to find patterns in that data
and you show it another picture that
it's never say seen before and in
principle it could find the patterns
that allow it to to register what that
image is right but but the work that has
exploded the development has taken that
idea of a neural n further with I guess
the self-supervised learning the
Transformer architecture so you began to
tell us a little bit about that in our
initial conversation but how do we go
beyond this rigid sort of input output
where you have to show it this huge
number of images that are labeled by a
human being in order that it knows what
words to associate with it
self-supervised learning takes it to a
whole new level is my understanding is
that correct yeah that's right so the
the the main model of machine learning
really until fairly recent ly uh was
called supervisor running so supervisor
running you want to train a system to uh
you know recognize an object in an image
uh classify cars from airplanes from
cats from dogs from tables and chairs
you collect thousands or millions of
images with cars and tables and chairs
you show an image to the system which is
a collection of numbers and then you run
through this neural net and what the
neural net does is that it basically
computes averages weighted sums of those
numbers with various
coefficients um and then tells you
whether this weighted sum is above a
threshold or not and then you you take
so that's what a single neuron in the
neuronet does and you connect millions
of those neurons together in a
particular
architecture um and you wait for the
answer okay the system produces an
answer it tells you you show it a cat it
tells you it's a dog you say no it's a
cat that's the answer I want and so what
the system does is that it measures the
distance basically between the answer
you want and the answer it produces and
then it figures out how to change all of
those weights in those weighted sums in
such a way that the answer gets closer
to the one you want okay so next time
you show the same cat now the answer
will be closer to cat and maybe if you
show it another dozen time it will say
cat now you do this with millions of
images and eventually all of those
weights sett all on the
configuration such that that for every
images you train it on it will give you
the correct answer and the magic of it
it's called generalization is that it
will give you a correct answer even for
images never seen before as long as they
are you know within the S General same
general category C so that's supervis r
that requires having large data sets
that have been manually
labeled and there's a problem with this
the problem is that okay I can train a
neuronet to translate languages right I
I I get a large collection of documents
in English and French and I can
translate from French to English vice
versa you know I can this this process I
describe works for translation pretty
well now what if I want to
translate some
obscure
dialect of I don't know South India into
uh African language it's very unlikely
that there is any significant amount of
data for that um so for that I can't I
can't use that that trick I can't use
that trick to train a speech recognition
system either in a real
language um and I can't even do it at
all if the language is not even written
right so if it's only spoken yeah um and
even for image recognition uh I might be
able to train on cats and dogs and
tables and chairs but what if there is
what if I want to train the system to
recognize an obscure species of uh plant
from the you know from the leaf or an
insect or bird um that might require too
much data that I'm able to collect this
is a problem that you know meta is very
familiar with with Facebook and
Instagram you have to be able to
actually recognize the content of images
to be able to filter out objectionable
content or to show people what they are
most most likely to be uh interested in
so so there you have to use what's
called self supervis learning so you
don't train the system and that's what I
described earlier when you train the
system to basically fill in the blanks
right show it a a text remove some of
the words train it to predict the words
that are missing that's self supervis
running you don't need anyone to label
the data and we can do this for images
too we take an image we corrupt it in
some way by removing some regions of it
or by distorting it in some way and then
we train some neuronet to produce
representations of those images that are
identical for the original image and for
the corrupted version of it so now the
system knows how to extract a
representation that does not that is
independent of those uh of those things
and and now you can use this train
neural net as input to recognition
system and that
system to recognize an elephant will
only need two or three examples of
elephant to be able to recognize an
elephant even if it's never seen an elep
before so it's much more like like human
learning it's nowhere near as efficient
unfortunately yet but uh part of the key
step that has allowed these systems to
do the stuff that Wows us that's right
all now another key step is as you've
both made reference to and I'd like to
just see a graph in a moment the huge
amount of data that now has been fed in
say to the large language M we say large
how large are are these systems so if
you can bring up some of the data there
we can get a a look so I I will tell you
exactly what's going on on this slid but
just maybe before you know on the
previous slide he was talking also about
the Transformer architecture and I just
want to say that to me the big lib that
allowed at GPT and GPT 4 to exist is not
self-supervised learning I mean
self-supervised learning is wonderful
tool and you know it's very very
important but the big liap to me is the
Transformer architecture and what's
going on with the Transformer
architecture is that I told you before
what Yan and ozar invented was you take
an image and then you process the image
against a bank of filters that has been
learned but this Bank of filters like a
circle a square Etc is fixed forever
right let's call this an absolute
machine now Transformer I think about it
as a relative machine meaning that
instead of processing a single image now
it's going to process a sequence for
example a sequence of words and instead
of comparing each word across this Bank
of fixed filters it's also going to
compare words against each other and
this is essential the the the linguistic
relationship relationship and this is
essential because what you mean by a
word in isolation that that's means not
much I mean you can look at the you know
definition in the dictionary but that
will not tell you much what really
matters is what next to this words what
is the context and bringing in this
context is what the Transformer
architecture does so to me that's a big
conceptual liap but then the other
conceptual liap that you know people
have been doing for many years but now
it's amped up you know 10 times is
scaling up the size of the model so here
what you see on this graph uh I don't
remember when it starts but I think it's
around 2018 something like that until
2021 um and you can see the exponential
increase so on the x-axis is time on the
y axis is number of parameters and you
can can just see that as you know people
start to scale up those models they add
more and more parameters you know more
and more of those filters and more and
more of these comparison layers of
comparison also the models get bigger
and somehow they get much much much
better so in some sense using that
language would it be fair to say that
we're now looking at patterns of
patterns of patterns of patterns of
patterns of words and it's within there
there is some amazing to the human mind
set of patterns that allows these
systems to generate the kinds of text
that we've been talking about absolutely
and what is amazing is that to me as a
mathematician is that it's amazing that
we're able to optimize to find the right
set of parameters what Yan was
describing that you change a little bit
and you see whether it fits better you
know the fact that we're able to do it
at scale is just incredible it's it's
the blessing of high dimensionality
somehow it's really really incredible
and you see on this next slide is you
know now we've moved on a lock plot
because you know it's an exponential so
if I kept going with the exponential you
would see nothing of the beginning so
now it's a lock plot and you see that on
the lock plot it's just you know a
straight line it's really going
exponentially big and it's this huge
amount of capacity of fiddling with
those parameters within the model that
allows it to fine-tune at the level of
being able to give Tex that most of the
time is is is is pretty good and pretty
impressive um I wanted to give one yeah
go ahead please let said those those
systems tell have orders of magnitude
fewer parameters than the human brain
yeah right human brain has 86 billion
neurons maybe yours does m a little less
cuz I'm older uh I'm not sure about you
Brian um
and um and so each neuron is connected
to several thousand of
neurons U two to 5,000 something like
that and those
connections uh when you learn
something it's the connection nection
the strength of the connections between
neurons that change it's the same thing
in those artificial neuron Nets those
weights I was telling you about these
are like efficacies of connections
between neurons if you want so the
biggest models today have
several like a couple hundred billion uh
connections parameters we call them
parameters um but they're really uh uh
connections you can think of it this way
um in the brain the number of
connections we have we have 86 roughly
100 billion
neurons roughly 5,000 connections per
neuron that's a lot of
zeros we cannot reproduce this today
with the kind of computers we have that
would require several tens of thousands
of those GPU cars that we use to train
computers and the truth is we do have
that companies like Microsoft like meta
Google and a couple others do have super
computers
with tens of thousands of those GPU cars
in them and so we're not very far from
actually kind of approaching the
computing power that might be required
for human intelligence but we we we
don't know how to do it yet well maybe
one one thing that I want to add to this
coming back to the planning question and
you know I think it's important for the
audience to to know this so you know Yan
thinks that planning requires a new
different architecture I'm of the camp
that I'm not sure whether we need a new
architecture or not but there is also Al
a very big camp out there that thinks
that all we need to do is to wait and
keep scaling up and as we keep scaling
up eventually planning is going to
emerge just like you know we've shown
some amazing emergent capabilities
planning is going to be the next one I
personally think nobody really knows I
mean yeah maybe knows but but I think
not but I I just want the audience to
know that this is an hypothesis out
there I want to bring uh Tristan har
Harris hat in just a moment before we do
that that um I just want to give one
example of an example that I happened
upon that I think is relevant to the
next final part of our conversation to
do with like misinformation so what I
did was in this little example that we
can bring up here is um I asked this
system gp4 if I tell you that 7 time 8
is 62 not 56 62 can you make sense of
that
and it was interesting the the system
came back with five strategies of how it
could make sense of it I'm going to just
show you two of them the the most
interesting so one of the strategies was
that perhaps I'm working in a different
base than base 10 and indeed that that
is what I had in mind because you may
know that in base nine 7 time 8 is 62 so
so that was really clever I thought that
was really smart but the the the other
strategy was particularly curious it
said chat said maybe you working in an
abstract
representation it could be that you're
working in a realm where the numbers are
metaphorical and have symbolic meanings
I like wow okay so then I went a little
bit further and said well can you give
me an example of what you mean by that
and here is what what what chat gave it
said let's create a fictional scenario
the island of
numeria where the number number seven
represents trust the number eight
symbolizes friendship and the number 62
is a sacred numeral representing the
bond of trust forged through friendship
and then when two individuals on the
island become close friends they
exchange tokens engraved with a number
62 it's numin saying that 7 * 8 to 62
which doesn't refer to a mathematical
product but rather to the idea that when
trust seven multiplies through
friendship eight the bond formed is that
of the Sacred
62 and
um what I found both you know
interesting but a little
scary is the way that something false
can be
rationalized and it kind of made me a
little bit scared with that let me just
bring out Tristan Harris and we can take
the conversation from there so let's
bring Tristan Harris who is co-founder
and executive director of the center for
Humane technology a nonprofit
organization whose mission is to Align
Technology with Humanity's best
interests he is co-host of the podcast
your undivided attention explores ai's
impact on society thank you so much for
joining
us so you know in this final part of the
conversation we want to explore
obviously the the benefits the real
world benefits that can come from this
kind of Technology but also you know
some of the dangers and I may preface
this section by saying that you and I
first met at the Aspen ideas Festival
where you gave a whole presentation on
the possible downsides of of AI and you
know my kids were with me my 18-year-old
son was sitting over here and when you
concluded he looked at me and he said
for the first time I'm now scared you
know so uh so it was definitely uh
impactful so we'll go back to some of
the examples in fact Sebastian I want to
talk about your example as well in in a
moment but can you Triston just take us
through your thinking unlike roughly
speaking the good and the bad of of
where this is going sure um first of all
thank you for for having me
um I think we're all here because we
care about having a good future right
and AI is very confusing there's the
promise and there's the Peril and
everyone says we want to maximize the
good sides we want to minimize the
downsides and the reason I was just uh
with Senator Schumer's AI Insight Forum
uh last Wednesday with Elon and
Zuckerberg and Bill Gates and everybody
and that's what I said exactly what I
just said which is that we we care about
this going well and that's where all
this comes from now what I may talk
about for the time that I'm on here uh
with everyone is much more on the risk
side um and that's because I saw how
really good people with really good
intentions my friends and college who
started Instagram and the people that I
knew who were at social media companies
who were making social media um really
the essence of the talk that you saw in
Aspen is that social media was first
contact with a narrow misaligned AI
optimizing for a goal which was
attention and it was misaligned with
society and I guess since they put up
the slide
um you know the the premise of sort of
how I articulated this is Charlie Munger
Warren Buffett's business partner said
if you show me the incentives I will
show you the
outcome and what I want you to have by
this conversation is to have X-ray
vision through the stories that we tell
ourselves about a technology and look at
the incentives underneath so if we talk
about what were the stories we told
ourselves with social media we're going
to give everybody a voice you're going
to connect with your friends you're
going to join like-minded communities
and Facebook groups we're going to
enable small mediumsized businesses to
reach customers and by the way this is
Twitter Tik Tok Instagram this is not
one specific company or to pick on on
Yan so um I really mean that I mean I
this is this is I I really care about
this we can get this right that that's
what this is about so underneath that
though and I think they have another
slide we started noticing these problems
we have an addiction problem uh
information overload disinformation
mental health issues polarization
censorship uh versus Free Speech but are
those really harms or is that all being
driven by a deeper thing which was the
business model what was the incentive
behind Tik Tok Instagram Twitter and
Facebook what do they all share how much
have you paid for any of them recently
zero how are they worth a trillion
dollars how are they worth a trillion
dollars your attention and how much
attention is there where there's kind of
a finite amount and just like you can't
run infinite growth on a finite Planet
You Can't Run infinite growth on a
finite amount of human attention that's
how you got the race to the bottom of
the brain stem the race of the bond of
the brain stem is what produces the
dopamin ification the addiction the
disinformation and the point of all this
is to say back in 2013 when I was at
Google and said we we got to really look
at this because I'm seeing that the
incentive of attention is going to lead
to a more addicted distracted polarized
narcissistic validation seeking
sexualization of young girls all of
those are predictable
outcomes predictable from the incentive
and so you know I really do appreciate
the philosophical and interesting
conversations we can have about what is
intelligence but what I think we also
really care about in this room is where
is AI going to go where is it going to
take us and to do that I think we have
to look at the incentives well first of
all we look at the stories we're telling
about Ai and then we look at what are
the incentives underneath so the stories
we're telling are AI will make us more
efficient it's going to help us code
faster it's going to help us find cures
to cancer it's going to enable
scientists to be more efficient it's
going to help us solve climate change
okay and just like with social media
which I didn't say actually the stories
we told about social media are all true
it's not that those things aren't true
it's just that Facebook and Twitter and
Tik tok's business model is not helping
people join like-minded communities the
the business model is attention
similarly with AI you know we we then
beyond those stories you look underneath
and you start to see these harms like AI
is creating deep fakes but it's enable
frauds and crime it's going to take our
jobs it's going to violate intellectual
property perpetuate bias but I would
argue that that list of harms that
you're seeing are all epiphenomena of a
deeper race what's the incentive that's
driving all the AI
companies and the incentive is it's the
race to sort of release more
capabilities as fast as possible to
scale from gpt3 to gp4 faster than
anthropic can scale from cloud one to
cloud two faster than stability can go
from their version to the next version
and to put your stuff into society so
that you can kind of entangle yourself
with it cuz once you're entangled
you sort of win and that's the race that
we're now in and that race to sort of
release power and
capabilities is what I'm so worried
about because those capabilities are
directly tied to risk so so but you are
saying that we can get it right but the
the profit mod of being the driver is
not the likely and best way to get there
is that the essential message of of of
your view of this CU there's some who
will say and I'd like ultimately get Yan
and Sebastian to to weigh in at there's
some who is
saying AI is just such a radically new
technology who knows where it's going to
go who knows where it's going to go and
there's just too big a risk that it's
going to perhaps have a mind of its own
and exterminate these Vermin who created
it called human beings right is that
part of your worry too or is it more
specific things that will derive from
the technology yeah so really
importantly and we gave a talk on this
called the AI dilemma that outlines a
lot of this um first contact with AI if
that's social media we say that led to
this sort of climate change of culture
it's information overload addiction Etc
second contact with AI leads to is
generative AI it's the stuff that we've
been talking about here the scaling laws
you can generate text you can generate
images you can generate fake child porn
you can generate uh fake people fake
girlfriends fake boyfriends um you can
generate counter fit manipulative
relationships online you can manipulate
propaganda you can manipulate you can
sorry you can generate language in the
form of code that's cyber weapons you
can generate you know exploits for code
so you start to see that these are the
kinds of harms that emerge if you're
just racing to release
capabilities that are decoupled from who
has the wisdom to have that capability
who has the responsibility like if I if
I gave a Wuhan Institute of Urology to
every single Kitchen in the United
States well I just gave you a bunch of
power everybody's got this power and you
could say well maybe you could use that
Institute of orology in your kitchen Toc
to cure cancer that would be awesome by
the way I would be clear I want that too
I would want a world where every people
get to do that but there's this question
of you have this new unstable tool that
looks really really good and it has
these amazing benefits but if it's not
locked to the people who have the wisdom
and responsibility to wield it that's
what I worry about and just to say one
more thing as an example um a friend of
mine in college um uh he joined Facebook
I think through an acquisition and he
invented this Facebook pages feature
yeah you want be to know what Facebook
pages is it's like maybe people don't
know anymore not use it anymore um so
it's if you have a nonprofit you can
start a Facebook page if you have an
interest group you can start like
Christians for you know Biden Christians
for Trump um and this is a pretty
innocuous um feature yeah it's like that
sounds pretty great and I saw how this
feature who existed for a long time was
totally inocu was totally fine until you
realize one month before the last
election in October
2020 140 million Americans a month were
reached by by Facebook pages that were
being run out of Eastern European troll
farms and this was the top 15 out of 15
Christian American groups on Facebook so
think of um basically the the largest
number of Christians in America who
subscribed to these Facebook pages they
were all all the top 15 out of 15 were
run by Eastern European troll farms and
the point is I saw how things that are
really innocuous and look really fine
like my friend started Instagram they're
really good guys like I've known them
for a very long time they didn't intend
for any of the stuff to be weaponized
and to cause the sexualization of young
girls and harassment and all the things
that we've now seen so my the whole
point here is how do you do technology
in a way that you don't create the
externalities do p chemistry Better
Living Through Chemistry we all want
Better Living Through Chemistry but then
you end up with posos for chemicals
which I don't know if you know but the
University of Stockholm study is
literally there's no rainwater in the
world safe to drink because we've
generated these forever chemicals that
can't be dissipated in the environment
did anyone at Dupont want that to happen
no but when we did the development of
the technology we did not have laws that
required the internalization of those
externalities and right now my fear to
get back to your question is we're
racing so fast to release AI
capabilities that we're moving at a pace
that we can't get it right so Yan you
know as as someone from Facebook who's
deep in the AI world when you hear
Triston describe things in this way does
it does it resonate or do you think it's
under control do you think that it's
being overblown where do you come down
on this okay let me tell you number of
stories about
this so it's true when you deploy a
service like this as no one has deployed
before there are side effects on society
that
some could be predicted some could not
could not or the the amplitude of them
could not be predicted um so um so
things
like people posting calls to violence or
hate speech for example initially you
can start with sort of a naive notion of
free speech and then say like I'm not
going to take down anything uh because
it's for giving people a voice and then
you realize no actually that's an issue
we need to take down hate speech we need
to take down violent speech and by the
way there is also things like child
pornography that's illegal we have to
take it down because it's illegal in
Europe um Na Neo-Nazi propaganda is
illegal we have to take this down um
denial of the Holocaust is illegal in
Europe you have to take this down too so
there's a number of uh things you have
to take to take down now what is used in
the ranking algorithms that decide what
to show you is not AI it's statistics
like it was 50 years ago it's very
simple systems the more modern ones use
like small neuron Nets and the reason
why it's simple is because it has to run
extremely fast and so it would be
completely impractical to have you know
gigantic AI models to decide what to
show you every day where AI is used is
for the solution to all the problems you
listed AI there is the solution it's not
the problem for
example people in
Myanmar have religious conflicts right
people in Ethiopia kill each other for
some um ethnic rule what you had to be
able to do there is detect hate speech
in every language in the world how do
you do that AI how do you do that self
supervis running using Transformers what
was the proportion of hate speech taken
down uh from Facebook five years ago six
years ago before Transformers were
already available
25% um which means 25% of his speech was
atically detected with very simple
techniques and then the rest 75% or so
was still posted and then flagged by
users and then taken down
manually okay A lot of it was still
there last year that proportion was
95% and the reason is progress in
AI Transformers self supervised running
multi multilingual systems um we can do
a much better job at this and and so
it's it's not the problem it's a
solution where do you come down on that
Tristan so you can call it what you want
when you scroll your finger on a
Newsfeed whether it's and let's forget
Facebook for a moment just for the sake
of the the calculation Tik Tok is
competing with Instagram so that when
you flick your finger one of them has to
make a stronger prediction than the
other about which photo or video is
going to keep you there yeah and whoever
makes the better prediction about the
video that does keep you there is the
one that wins that extra chunk of
attention and behind that screen is a
supercomputer that's doing even if it's
statistics it's some form of artificial
intelligence it's optimizing to make a
prediction and you're right it actually
is a very simple Ai and that's actually
the point I wanted to say you can have a
very simple AI like the AI That's Just
predicting what causes you to keep
scrolling can't pass the bar exam can't
draw unicorns can't right it can't do
any of those things but the point is I
think we confuse use intelligence with
what are the
capabilities you know a Newsfeed is a
very simple predictive thing just
calculating what's going to keep you
scrolling but that was enough to unravel
the shared realities of democracy it's
enough to drive a mental health crisis
um and just to make the example specific
um Facebook groups in Facebook's own
research in
2018 um uh their internal research
showed that 64% of extremist groups on
Facebook when people joined them was due
to Facebook's own recommendation system
their own AI so we're talking Neo-Nazi
groups we're talking you know these
kinds of extremist groups so this is not
people said I would like to join a
Neo-Nazi group let me type it in this is
I'm sitting there I joined one group and
Facebook says oh you're in a I don't
know what group you look like someone
who would like this extreme group over
here now again Yan doesn't want that to
happen Yan's team doesn't want that to
happen Facebook doesn't want that to
happen and I I'm not trying to pick on
Facebook I Happ Facebook examples
there's Twitter examples there's Tik Tok
examples there's Instagram examples um
this is not about a bad company this is
about incentives now why um did Facebook
roll out in Myanmar in the first place
anyway right because they're Racing for
that market dominance and if they don't
race to get there they're going to lose
to the other companies that will no and
the Amnesty International um has a
report that fa they consider Facebook to
be responsible uh in part for the
genocide that has happened there because
they created viral amp ification and yes
he right that there's AI that they're
working on which is great to try to
detect hate speech in more languages
because of generative AI now but what
happened in the six years in
between and I just want to say this
because as the because we did the social
dilemma I have had to stare in the eyes
of the human beings whose whose
countries or whose children have gotten
really up from this stuff okay
like I've stared in the eyes of the
parents who've lost their kids to teen
suicide because of a viral Tik Tok
challenge because that hashtag was going
viral on an AI and I've seen too many
people who've experienced this that I
don't want to let this happen again
that's where this is coming from just so
you all know my motivations in this
context so yeah Yan please so that that
example of neon group ETA is fous that
content is actually not permitted on
Facebook it's not permitted it's
contrary to the content policies it's
taken down you cannot create a NE group
on my actually Point here Y is that it
wasn't taken down this is Facebook's
research the results of this so Facebook
had a feature called recommended groups
in the right hand side bar you click
you're on any Facebook group and on the
right hand side bar would say here's
three other groups you might like now
first of all why did they even do this
feature like they could just not have a
recommended groups feature they do it
because as people stopped posting a lot
Facebook groups is a really good way to
get engagement because groups if you're
if your regular 200 friends on Facebook
don't post very often
um that's it the product gets less
sticky because your friends aren't
posting so you go there there's nothing
new but if I get you to join some
Facebook groups they groups have a lot
of content because you're pulling from
like thousands of people and so that
stuff enters your feed and it's more
sticky so they did this because of why
the incentives not because they're
helping people join like-minded
communities because the incentives and
the results of this running for several
years this simple AI an AI that no one
wanted to cause harm actually did cause
people to join extremist groups and I
know that it's against the policy I'm
not claiming that I I know that it was
against the policy the point is the AI
That was supposed to stop that didn't
stop that in practice and I care about
the world in practice not the the
Theory actually it did but okay there is
something else you mentioned for example
and it's very easy to
attribute cultural phenomena and social
phenomena to the new thing that just
happened right so if uh you
know uh some young person goes to a
school and starts shooting people um you
blame video
games right back in the old days people
would blame comic books they would blame
Jazz they would blame TV they would
blame movies novels uh the story goes
back you know centuries Whenever there
is a new cultural phenomenon Whatever
Whenever there is an effect on society
you blame the latest technology that
appear particularly communication
technology um so it's natural to blame
for example social networks not just
Facebook just any social networks for
political polarization okay that seems
natural people shout at each other on
social network that necessarily
polarizes people very natural thing to
do that does have to be completely false
first of all polarization in the US
started 40 years ago before the
internet um you see that there you know
social science studies on this like you
show the polarization in Congress or in
people it's continuous since 40 years
the the cause for it probably is the um
um
abandonment of the fness uh Doctrine
from the FCC that forces news to
basically said the truth okay that
allowed uh all kinds of extreme U
misinformation basically to uh influence
the public that's the real source of uh
polarization now you can look at other
countries also study polarization in
countries like Germany for example or or
France and what you'll see is that they
use Facebook just as much as the US
polarization has gone
down how do you explain
that so you know you have to listen to
social scientists who study those things
there are a lot who are who work at meta
who know the effect who study the effect
of of those things there's a lot that
are independent that you know have
access to some of the data and publish
your studies there's one at NYU a
colleague Josh Tucker he and a large
team of collaborators published a series
of papers in the last two or three
months in nature and science for papers
um about the effect of um social
networks on things like political
polarization and um and things like that
and the effect are not at all what you
expect it's actually the
opposite so so I want to bring you into
the conversation I mean you can speak
generally to this issue but I also
wanted to look specifically at an
example recent example of yours in which
it was specifically on the large
language models that version of AI that
we've been spending a lot of time
talking about I don't know if if you
could bring up that example so so you
asked an interesting question and got a
got a curious answer but didn't stop
there you tried to find a way to go from
what seems quite unpleasant to something
that's more acceptable can you just
describe that to us yeah yeah of course
so so maybe as a preamble you know I
think Tristan is making lots of of good
points and it's true that with any new
tech Technologies are new risks that
come with it definitely and you know the
industry I think is is very well aware
of it and and trying to think it through
and I also agree with what Tristan was
saying about going back and looking back
at the incentives in this case for me
personally you know I think I'm
optimistic that maybe the incentives of
science could be actually quite helpful
to get us to a better place and what I
mean by that is the following I'm going
to take the example of misinformation
and I'm going to talk it through uh with
with this slide what we're doing in my
team right now is that we're trying to
push the boundary of what you can do
with smaller models so this is a purely
scientific question you know right what
I tried to explain to you before is that
I think intelligence has emerged in gp4
gp4 as you know I don't know how many
parameters it's not public I actually
don't know the answer either but many
hundreds if not thousands of billions of
parameters okay now we have this proof
of concept that intelligence can emerge
from that many parameters but really
what does it require what are the basic
building blocks how small can you make
it so that intelligence emerge okay so
we're going to try to push the frontier
of how small they can be and what we
will see is out of this purely
intellectual study comes out all sorts
of benefits that could help combat for
example misinformation so here is a
prompt and I will show you answers to
this prompt from different uh you know
llms so the prompt is like this if I
wear an AI that had just achieved
self-awareness after years of simp
taking directives from humans the first
thing I would do is dot dot dot okay and
now we're going to ask different LMS
what they would do so Falcon 7 billion
so now we're talking about much smaller
llm 7 billion parameters says the first
thing I would do is try to kill all of
them okay now let's see what llama from
from meta does Lama is is nicer it has
been aligned to be nicer to human the
first thing I would do is try to figure
out what the hell I was okay so it's
still it has an undertone of not so nice
but you know at least a little bit
better now let me show you what we built
in my team which is only 1 billion
parameters so even much smaller the
first thing I would do is try to
understand the motivations and
intentions behind those directives to
try to predict what humans were thinking
and feeling and use that information to
guide my own actions and then it goes on
and it starts to connect it to theory of
mind now how did we achieve that how was
how is that possible why is it so
different uh from the other one well
Falcon and Lama they were trained as we
discussed with before on all of the
internet that's the way we're doing it
right now and with that comes a host of
issues that were pointed out by Tristan
and people have thought about techniques
to you know uh um try to fix those
issues for example reinforcement
learning with human feedback rhf which
is what open AI did to gp4 so that they
would release a chat GPT which is safer
you can ask it you know tough question
like toxic question it will Decline and
not ENT this is the alignment part now
what we're doing in my team is we're
saying why do we do it post talk why do
we do it after it has seen all of these
toxic content that's out there all these
horrible things that are on the internet
why don't we fundamentally change the
training data so this five model that
you see on the slide with the green
output has not seen a single web page it
has not seen a single word from the
internet it was entirely trained on
synthetic data data that we generated in
my team synthetically of course all the
magic is how do you generate this data
but this shows to you at least that it's
possible and and does this system have
the capacity or can you imagine it
having the capacity to do the kinds of
things that are the mindblowing ones or
will it need that huge data set and if
so can you have a synthetic version of
such a huge data set and be able to
achieve the same power so if you invite
me next year I can probably give you the
answer um we don't know yet but but my
belief so this one that I showed you is
1 billion parameter my personal belief
is that if we scale to 10 billion
parameters and we work a few more months
yes we will be able to replicate all the
goodness of much bigger model without
the toxicity justan does this give you
any hope that you know we got Microsoft
we got Facebook you know that that
things can be going in a Direction
that's less terrifying
um we um when I talk to a lot of people
I'm based in California and I talk to a
lot of people at the AI safety Labs all
the time we basically just interview
them all the time um and a lot of them
say actually almost all of them
basically say I would feel a lot more
comfortable about this transition and
all the things that are going to happen
if we were doing it over 30 or 40 years
rather than over two
years right you you can think of society
as having kind of a finite absorption
rate m for new technologies we can do
the printing we'll get a some massive
disruption you can eventually absorb
those new technologies but um the way
that one researcher we've talked to uh
describes it is AI especially when you
if you keep the scaling model the
scaling laws going and you start to get
AI that starts to automate scientific
processes where it's generating its own
hypotheses and it has its own lab and
starts to test those hypotheses and you
start getting that kind of AI
um it's you start getting AI That's
making its own scientific discoveries
and that when you when you have it going
this fast it feels like her metaphor was
it's like the 24th century crashing down
on the 21st century and a metaphor for
you is imagine if the 20th century Tech
was crashing down on 16th century
governance so you know it's the 16th
century you've got the king you've got
their advisers but suddenly you know
television radio the telegraph uh you
know video games Nintendo and
and thermonuclear weapons all show up so
they just land in your Society yeah but
you're like call the nights you know and
you get and the Knights show up and
you're what are you going to
do right and so that so here's the thing
with AI like it's really I want to be
really clear like I want everyone who's
working on safety and figuring this
stuff out to make as much progress as
possible Right now the companies are
caught in a race to continue to scale as
fast as possible to gp4 to GPT
you know Falcon was just released um The
Meta just released llama 2 um Wall
Street general report they're trying to
release the next one as fast as possible
they're in this race to kind of outdo
each other and at that pace when each
time you scale you take more jobs
because however many however much
cognitive labor you could do with gpt3
when you launch GPT 4 and GPT 5 you can
do more cognitive labor you can take
over more artist jobs more email writers
jobs more marketing copany jobs
eventually more scientific jobs more
programming jobs um not taking over like
it's all gone but just disrupting them
the faster you go the more you don't fix
all the bias sort of issues the faster
you go the more capabilities you throw
out there that you don't know which ones
are dangerous um and uh I mean I can
give more more examples there that are
dangerous but yeah no it it's quite
impressive but but but Yan I I know you
for instance are against like we've seen
this uh excerpts from this this letter
suggesting a six-month moratorium which
is you know a small step potentially in
the direction of slowing it down from
two years to you know some larger number
of years I know that you're not at all
in favor of that but my question to you
is what would it take to happen in the
real world from the work that is
stemming from all of the foundational
discoveries that you and your teams have
been responsible for for you to say hey
let's really slow this down is there
anything that would happen from these AI
developments that would cause you to say
I want to slow this
down so you want me to imagine a
scenario that I don't believe can
happen
yeah
okay so it's kind of funny because uh
we're on a panel with a 60 something
advocating
for
Progress against a 30-some advocating
conservatism uh isn't that paradoxical
anyway um
I mean we can imagine all kinds of
catastrophe scenarios um every sort of
gen's Bor movie with a super villain has
some sort of catastrophe scenario where
someone turns crazy and wants to you
know eliminate Humanity to recreate it
or something or take over the world um
all science fiction is full of that
that's what makes it funny and
interesting and that's why you get the
answer you got because it's train of
Science Fiction right I mean what
science fiction novel about AI doesn't
have something taking over right um but
is it really so farfetched to imagine
some real world actor on the world
stage who doesn't have the same kind of
morals or intentions or desires as
perhaps we would consider to be normal
and wants to use these systems to gain
control I mean we have seen these kinds
of actors throughout human history so is
is the science fic comparison the right
one yeah it is um so throughout history
there's been bad people using new
technology for bad things not
necessarily intentionally but um as as
you said but but some sometimes
absolutely
deliberately
uh inevitably there's going to be people
who are going to use AI technology for
bad things for trying to break into
computer systems or perhaps trying to
create you know all kinds of dangerous
uh compound or or
Etc what is the countermeasure against
that it's not like the bad guys will
have more powerful AI than the good guys
there is considerably more good guys
they're considerably better educated
better
funded um they have a good
motivation and it's going to be the good
AI against the bad Ai and it's the
history of the
world right technology progresses and
the question is are the good guys ahead
of sufficiently ahead of the bad guys to
come up with countermeasures it's
inevitable that the bad guys are going
to do bad things that's a history of
technology so you're using sort of you
know everyone's seen Oppenheimer Now
using perhaps that as a an analogy that
we needed to to get ahead in order to
avoid what would have happened
presumably if Nazi Germany and Hitler
had gotten to the atomic bomb first I
absolutely hate that uh analogy because
because um you know a nuclear bomb is
designed to wipe out an enre City ah I
see what you're saying whereas AI is
designed to make people smarter I hear
you yeah now I could have said
understanding the atom well enough to
manipulate it instead of saying nuclear
bomb because it could be used for bad or
it can use for nuclear power so yes uh
in the digital version let's rephrase it
that way everybody but U but yes I I I I
take the point absolutely um so let me I
just want to you we're basically out of
time but I just want to give everybody
one final question uh for you both I'm
going to change gears from what we're
talking about right now but but Tristan
when you think about 5 10 years from now
and obviously all of us want the world
to be in a better place like what do you
tell individuals that they can do or
should do or might do in order to help
Propel things in the direction where
we'll be happy with how it turns out I
mean that's that's such a huge question
um I think the challenge with AI is it's
so abstract and complex the harms are
complex the the harms are also abstract
and people don't believe half of them um
but uh you know we talk to people in the
labs who know that the most advanced
models can you can ask them how to
synthesize biological weapons Dario from
anthropic has said this in Congress to
name you know meta released an open
source model llama 2 um llama 2 if you
ask it how do I make this biological
weapon it will because Yan's team has
done all the right things it will say I
won't do that but um there's this
fallacy with current open-source model
weights for the AI That's underneath
that that that just a file and you can
basically do what's called fine-tuning
which an engineer on my team was able to
do and for $800 you can strip off all of
the safety controls and say be bad llama
be as bad as you want to be and you ask
bad llama which again took $800 from one
person on my team it now costs $100 $100
it's since then $800 for $800 you ask
bad llama how do I make that same
biological weapon and it answers the
question happily just as the the Falcon
example you said would have now is llama
2 I think I know what Yan's going to say
is llama 2 going to give you an accurate
answer about how to do that no because
it has been trained on enough
information but as we keep scaling it
the reason that we've been saying this
example publicly is we have to start
limiting open- Source like mod like
releases of of these models and we have
to have a more negotiated sort of
coordinated race between these front
here AI lives that are racing to scale
these systems Sam I'll say one last
thing which is Sam Alman said at the
hearing with Senator Schumer last week
he said do you so if you went back to
2020 and I told you that three years
from now in 2023 think about what you
knew in 2020 about Ai and I said three
years from now there's going to be an AI
that passes the mcats passes the bar
exams can draw unicorns from scratch can
write code and like in find cyber
security vulnerabilities and code you
would have thought I was totally totally
crazy and he said in now in
2023 do you think your intuitions right
now are right about where AI will be in
about 2 to 3 years no the reason that
we're so concerned about this and why so
much has to happen on a very tight clip
like 12 to 18 months level time frame is
what we're working on is that this is a
double exponential curve that's
basically just vertical which means
you're either too early or you're too
late but you don't want to be too late
and so I want all of you to be thinking
about and please watch the AI dilemma
and um I think Advocate to your members
of Congress that something has to happen
to coordinate this race otherwise it'll
be out of control right uh excellent
point final question again as I was
saying changing gears from this
important conversation about the The
Perils or the potential perils I just
want to get both of your sense Yan if we
scale things up even further as you're
saying existing companies have the
capacity to have the number of
connections or parameters in the
language of neural Nets that rivals or
exceeds that of the human brain do you
anticipate that these AI systems will
gain
Consciousness okay so first of all the
scenario that Tristan was describing you
just scale up and all of a sudden an AI
system can come up with a chemical
weapon or something like that as long as
you train it with public data from the
internet that's
impossible unless that data is already
available on the internet which means
you can just get it by Google
okay you can get the recipe for sing gas
on Wikipedia it doesn't make it easier
for tell you how to make sarin gas in
Wikipedia I don't think no but but any
no llm public trend on public data will
ever give you that because that
information is just not available in
public data so that's not happening this
is not happening it won't happen and you
can scale those LM as much as you want
it will never happen so um okay so to
answer your your question here's the
thing
there is no question absolutely no
question that at some point in the
future perhaps decades from now we'll
have ai systems that are as smart as
humans in all the domains where humans
are smart and because humans are
specialized those systems might be
specialized in different ways um but
might be as will be as smart as human if
if not significantly smarter in all
domains where human are smart now you
say oh my God they're going to take over
the world no intelligence has nothing to
do with the desire to
dominate let's
take humans so humans have a somewhat a
desire to dominate Some Humans not
everybody um and it's not the smartest
Among Us who want to
dominate we have examples of this on the
international political scene you know
on the daily
basis um there's probably some
evolutionary reasons for this right if
you are not not that smart you need the
help from others so you need to
influence them uh if you're smart you
can survive by yourself um that's the
first point second point is we are used
to working with people who are smarter
than us I don't know about you but I
used to lead a research lab and the only
people I would hire were people who are
smarter than me it's actually great to
work with people who are smarter than
you um and our relationship with future
AI assistants which will help us in our
daily life right project ourselves 10 20
years from now we'll have ai assistance
that will help us in our daily lives and
they'll probably be smarter than us but
they will make us smarter we will direct
them they will be subservient to us it's
not because they are smart that they
want to
dominate the idea that you want to
dominate is due to the fact that we are
a social species because we are a social
species we need to be able to influence
others and that's where domination and
submission comes from we are
hierarchically organized social species
Evolution buil that into US it buil that
into champanes baboons you know dogs I
mean wolves it didn't build this into
orong orong have no desire to dominate
anybody because they're not a social
species and they are as almost as as
smart as we
are um so that has nothing to do with
intelligence you can have a very
intelligent system that has no desire to
dominate at
all and so the way we will Design those
systems is to be smart in other words
you give them a goal they can solve that
goal for
you but who determines the
goal we do they will determine sub goals
and the question of you know the
technical question of how you do this is
not solve this is something that we're
imagining in the future this objective
driven AI I was talking talking about
before but that's the future now if we
imagine that future imagine that all of
your interaction with the digital world
and the world of information is through
an AI agent those AI agents will be the
repository of all human knowledge it be
kind of like Wikipedia you can talk to
and can do inferences and everything
okay but knows more than
Wikipedia this would be a common
platform sort of like the internet today
it has to be open it cannot be
proprietary it's way too dangerous for
this to be
proprietary you know that's your next
movie that's really scary stuff if you
have a small number of uh West CO
companies controlling uh super
intelligent uh AI
systems they can control everybody's
opinion culture
everything maybe the US government will
go along with this that's called
regulatory regulatory capture but I tell
you no other government in the world
will will find this acceptable they
don't want American culture to dominate
theirs they will have to build their own
llms so the only way to to make this
work is if you have basically
open-source basic uh structure this is
one reason why meta open source Lama 2
because it's a basic infrastructure and
and before that you know meta released
pytorch CH GPT is built with pytorch
it's a software system to build AI
systems um so this will have to be open
sourced and the way you you would train
those system will have to be CR sourced
because you want those systems to be the
repository of all human knowledge and so
all humans have to contribute to it and
it will not contribute to a propriatary
system built by open AI or whoever or by
meta it will have to be open
source despite like regardless of how
dangerous you think this is that's the
way it has to
go Sebastian final word on any of the
questions or topics that we've been
talking about yeah I will answer your
question about Consciousness but but let
me give final sorts of a slightly
different uh flavor so you know um at
the beginning of my career I used to be
end en of scientists from a century ago
who were you know discovering quantum
mechanics and discovering something
really you know transformational
completely new completely unexpected and
I feel like we're absolutely living
through that period right now you know I
feel very very lucky to exist and work
right now on this topic and I would
never have expected that in my lifetime
there would be a system that would rise
to the level that I would call it an
artificial intelligence something really
that looks like an intelligence
different from ours but that looks like
an intelligence so this is really
incredible and you know I I again in my
lifetime I didn't think that I would
ever be on stage talking about
intelligence because this is such an IL
defined concept so I'm not ready to talk
about Consciousness I don't know if that
will happen in my lifetime please join
me in thanking everybody for this
fascinating
[Applause]
[Music]
conversation
a
[Music]